[Musique]
faire
faire [
Musique]
le désert à l'extérieur de las vegas
[Musique]
donc dans le cas de las vegas la
réputation est que la foule s'ils
ne vous aiment pas ou s'ils voulaient tuer
quelqu'un
ils
les enterraient dans  le désert, ce dont nous n'avons jamais
vraiment parlé ou soupçonné, c'est
qu'ils
jetaient des corps dans le lac à Lake Mead
quand ils ont trouvé ce corps euh dans le
baril à Lake Mead euh
deux choses dont la police a dit qu'elles ont
définitivement attiré notre attention tout d'abord
ils ont déterminé  que le corps avait reçu
une balle dans la tête
donc c'était un meurtre victime de meurtre euh la
deuxième chose qu'ils ont
dit était que ce meurtre aurait
eu lieu à la fin des années 1970
ou au début des années 1980
donc
et la troisième chose est que le corps était
dans un  baril
[Musique]
donc
vous